so i recently did a few episodes on
making tests for programs we were doing
some putting some tests in the demo rpg
uh tutorial code long thing that i'm
doing i also asked on a community poll
or post if what people used to test and
there were just a few comments that
basically said i never test my code so
there are some people out there who
don't test and i just want to address
this and kind of give you my thoughts on
it
in general and the big thing the big
elephant in the room is is it okay to
not test your code
or should you definitely do it
well the short answer is you should
definitely do it but also
if it's just something you're working on
and probably never going to show anybody
else
then it doesn't necessarily matter so
much
but if you ever want anybody to take
your project seriously you should
probably have tests it is a red flag
for other developers when they look at
someone's repo on github and has no
tests they generally will assume that
it's
probably got bugs that the developer is
unaware of and it's sort of just gonna
be a
yeah just something to avoid because
there are better well tested things out
there or you could build your own of
whatever it is with test so in general
yeah you should definitely test and of
course the advantage to that for you
when you're testing your code is you
know that it actually works properly and
as you're adding to it and changing
things
you can just run your old tests and make
sure everything still works as intended
because we all know how it is there's
that one meme of the it's like someone
pulling down a baby's arm and it moves
up the other arm it's like yeah you
change one thing things happen in other
places
sort of a meme in programming where
yeah if you change one thing it does
weird stuff in other places so you
basically just have a great way of
testing and making sure
everything's working correctly and
yeah there's a little bit of overhead as
there usually is with anything that's
worthwhile where you gotta develop your
suite of tests but then once you have
them all made you don't really have to
do anything anymore other than
occasionally add to them when you add
new features
so it generally comes along with okay
you're adding some stuff add the test to
go with it
and voila you're done and
now people will take your repo more
seriously and you'll know that it works
correctly it's kind of a win-win so yeah
take the time to add tests and
if you're not
it's probably best to just not mention
it to be honest because it's also a red
flag for
any serious company
or something if you're trying to get a
job as a developer and they asked you
how do you do your tests and your
responses i don't test that's
that's sort of a okay let's not hire
this guy type of answer that you're
given so
i'm i just want to say yeah you should
learn at least learn some test based and
if someone is asking you at least tell
them that you know how and that you
prefer to test or something uh don't say
that you never test your code that just
makes you look really bad as a developer
even if you don't
test maybe your
main project that you work on that don't
you don't show anybody
uh you should still
know it and learn how to do it because
yeah you're gonna you're gonna be set
back if you don't basically in a lot of
different ways
so uh that's my rant about testing i
hope you enjoyed
and i'll see you guys around peace